[Music]
it's tuesday it's 2 p.m pacific it's
time for the lobby game spots weekly
hangout where we talk about video games
uh in this case final fantasy marvel vs
capcom 4 rumors uh we got a whole lot of
things to talk about today pete brown
what's up hi you're always on the show
how are you doing i'm good man i've been
super busy playing final fantasy 15 and
watch dogs too and as of today another
game last guardian yeah yeah
a couple games we
probably never thought we'd see and now
back to back yeah one after another yeah
yeah you've been had a tiring
thanksgiving week
yeah but it was it was good uh we can
get into it a bunch more but i was happy
to play a final fantasy 15 as much as i
uh had the chance to sweet i'm looking
forward to that eric tay what's up what
up so we're either talking about destiny
a fighting game or
overwatch if eric's on
eric which one we talking about
i don't know you tell me yeah
firefighting knows yeah uh so
just to jump right in uh recent report
emerged i think polygon was the first to
report on it saying that uh marvel vs
capcom 4 will be shown at psx which is
this weekend uh and you know like which
is weird because i think it was late
2014
marvel vs capcom origins got pulled from
like ps3 xbox 360 marketplace uh they
weren't like capcom wasn't completely
open with whether they would continue
the series uh obviously marvel vs capcom
3 being the last major entry but now it
appears according to substantial report
that we will be seeing marvel vs capcom
4 at psx this weekend for all intents
and purposes so we kind of wanted to
talk about what we might see in that
game what we want what characters would
do well and like what character we won't
see because
you know it's apparently it's only
marvel cinematic universe characters
which excludes the x-men which is kind
of a huge blow to the game did you play
uh marvelous capcom 3 a lotte yeah i
played a bunch of marvel vs capcom 3 and
ultimate marvel vs capcom 3 which is i
guess slightly newer than that version
um they're going to lose a lot of i
guess we'll start with that i guess
they're going to lose a bunch of core
kind of characters that have been in the
marvel versus capcom kind of series um
you know you're going to lose magneto
storm wolverine sentinel
these are some pretty big mainstays that
have been kind of throughout some of
them haven't been in all of them but
those like some of the ones i named have
been in i think all three um so it'd be
interesting to see it's not just x-men
too it's like deadpool
and then um super scroll i think because
that's fantastic four so because
whatever
marvel doesn't have our part in the mcu
yeah i saw people on like twitter saying
that's the equivalent of like if link
and pikachu weren't in smash or
something that's like the kind of how
big of a blow it is to this roster but
uh did you play
marvel vs capcom three a lot pete i
didn't play three so much but i've been
sort of you know i used to play all the
old 2d uh games uh starting you know
back when it was even just an x-men
fighting game right and then it was
street fighter vs x-men and then it was
marvel super heroes and it was marvel vs
street fighter and then marvel vs capcom
i played all of those and yeah like
x-men were a huge part of this series
like from the beginning so it will be
really strange to not be able to pull up
cyclops and wolverine right like two
pretty big omissions in my mind three i
kind of fell out of for some reason and
i don't know how i feel about four at
this point i don't really care about the
marvel cinematic universe i'm not i'm
not in love with those movies and i feel
like
what can i i don't know
what do i want to see from capcom
characters you know i don't even know
anymore like after five i feel kind of
apprehensive to get really excited about
another fighting game yeah
i mean like
think about capcom right now the closest
game that comes to mind right now is
resident evil 7 but that doesn't even
have like classic characters uh chris
redfield he was in three right yeah i
don't play much like many fighting games
i remember i played it for a little bit
and i enjoyed it just because i like a
lot of capcom games and i used to be
into marvel much more than i am now like
you pete i kind of
uh
fell out of k like keeping up with it
which is why like i'm not crazy excited
about this either i think according to
the report ant-man and groot from
guardians of the galaxy are very likely
characters um ant-man i have not seen
but i saw guardians of the galaxy and i
know gru is like a fan favorite so i'm
sure
there will be a lot of jokes surrounding
him but i kind of wanted to touch on
what kind of like
move sets they would have uh as eric as
your fighting expertise goes what they
might be doing also like considering you
know like to have wolverine cyclops
magneto are going to be omitted what
kind of fighters do they need now that
those several x-men are gone from the
franchise and whatnot i don't know
what's your take on like uh what kind of
roles these new mcu characters will fill
if they are confirmed this weekend
that's tough i mean i don't know how you
do ant-man though because ant-man
like you know if you watch the movie or
if you follow the comic like part of the
reason he's
so um like such a strong hero is because
he can change his size at any given time
you can't change your size to like this
little speck on the screen and then have
to deal with that i think that's kind of
insane you can't feel like ultra moves
though right
yeah i guess but i mean so ant-man
wasn't uh ultimate marvel versus capcom
3. but he only showed up when hawkeye
used him as his like level three super
he'd shoot ant-man off the tip of his
arrow and then ant-man would turn into
like a giant and then smash someone so i
don't know how ant-man would work
because like fighting rocket raccoon um
in marvel vs capcom 3 was already like
super annoying because he's super short
so his hitbox is like really small and
so like a lot of moves that normally hit
people don't hit them so i don't know
how ant-man will work so much
groot
i would imagine is just one other you
know kind of he'll probably be bigger
he'll be taller a little slower yeah
yeah he'll be like slower but he's gonna
have like reach and he'll probably do
like big damage and he probably can take
damage and i guess you can
kind of think of some of the stuff he
can do in just terms of like the movie i
guess because guardians of the galaxy um
and i don't know
i think it kind of makes sense though
because
to have a marvelous capcom 4 because
i feel like the longest time was would
marvel be okay with it more so than
capcom wanting to do it because i'm sure
capcom wants to do it right and i think
for marvel
it makes sense just because all these
movies keep coming out they're doing
like one every year or maybe more than
one once a year right and because of
that they probably can capitalize on the
fact that a lot of people are watching
these movies falling in love with these
heroes and want to play them in said
game what has me worried about marvel's
success since uh
um three whatever um
that game felt like a very much a capcom
fighting game right but like now marvel
has so much at stake with these
characters and with this game like how
much control or say are they going to
have over the visuals over you know
different things like will this be a
capcom joint or will this be a like
collaboration in a way that i think
people might not like yeah marvel's got
that i forget how long their road map is
for the mcu and it just stretches like
at least 10 years from now with all the
different spin-offs and all the
different heroes incorporated now that
like ant-man's around there's guardians
galaxy 2 was that officially announced
yeah that's coming like next year or
something and
it does seem like they're kind of much
more like the control freak than capcom
is especially considering capcom i
mistakenly said that residual seven is
the next game we have dead rising yeah
dead rising
um frank west was a character in he was
um i'm sure he'll make a return
especially if he's in dead rising four
um but again i can't i can't think of
any like new capcom characters that
might
be coming along for the roster i want
moira from revelations too yeah or barry
yeah barry burton would be awesome barry
would you say he's a resident no i don't
want moira she would just
awkwardly shout expletives for no good
reason characters from the baker family
from resident evil 7 just that just eat
you for their ultimate i mean i think
that trying to find new capcom
characters would be hard outside of like
maybe street fighter 5 maybe you try to
pull like a rashid in there or one of
their newer characters that they didn't
have previously in street fighter um but
they can also just go back right like
there are some characters that got
omitted in three that were in two that
were pretty big like captain commando
man yeah exactly um so there's there's
plenty of characters gin uh you know uh
so
and they can even go farther back if
they wanted to like rival school stuff
and and whatnot right i would love that
yeah so like this could be their chance
to like bring back some of those older
franchises that they maybe can't just
make a new rival schools or dark
stalkers even like they've had multiple
multiple dark stalker characters
throughout these marvel vs capcom games
and you know it'd be cool to see some of
those people come back like john talbane
or something um he would play fine i
think in in a marvel versus capcom world
uh dimitri would play fine because he's
almost like the ryu of that game you
know what i mean so
there's a lot that they could go with i
wonder if marvel can say to capcom no we
don't want that character fighting our
characters like i wonder if they can go
that oh i hate to speculate so
negatively but i just really want like i
really want to know how this new marvel
is going to handle a collaboration in a
field that they don't usually work in
yeah i feel like i think i don't know
maybe this is just me being
really open about it i guess it's just
like as long as
they stay true to the marvel characters
i feel like then that's
where i would expect you know their kind
of angst about it is like okay make sure
doctor strange is doctor strange make
sure you know these characters are these
characters and we can just imagine that
this world is like your characters get
to fight our characters but you got to
make sure that our characters are the
way they're supposed to be and you can
have your characters you know
right no of course i understand what
you're saying but like you could isn't
like uh
i'm trying there was like a baby in like
one of the capcom fighting games
i can't remember what it is
i think maybe it was just like a
it was a sidekick to another character i
could just imagine marvel saying like we
really don't want this little puny guy
beating up our superheroes you know
who knows i have to imagine i mean like
they were just some of the gameplay that
we were just watching showed like the
nemesis from resident evil 3 they get
like that's not the deepest cut but they
go pretty deep with some of these
characters i'm wondering like i said
between dead rising 4 resonant 7 i don't
know like it's tougher because it's an
rpg but i wonder if they'll pull from
monster hunter now at all if that would
be like a hunter or something just like
a generic kind of character like that i
have to wonder like what capcom and
marvel will be doing because marvel
obviously there's ones you can safely
assume will be like captain america thor
they'll be here least of all because
their movies have been doing really well
iron man will be around yeah he's been
in a bunch of them also i guess the
other side question i have not to get
too off tangent is that if this is
something that's going to be at psx is
this like a sony exclusive thing again
and is are any of those characters going
to make it in i think it's going to be a
psx because there's a capcom tournament
oh yeah street fighter
capcom right yeah i think that's just a
coincidence okay well yeah because i
mean like psx does announce like
non-exclusive things but like yeah look
when you look back at the last fighting
game street fighter 5 was exclusive for
how long
like i think it's just exclusive it's
just exclusive it was interesting and i
think
right yeah i have no idea i don't think
that got announced at psx2 from i was
talking to john luke about it earlier so
they announced that psx and then like
absolutely from the rap finals this year
yeah but capcom and they did not sell
enough copies of the street fighter 5
like they think they need the biggest
audience to get their hands on and i'm
sure marvel wants to hit the biggest
audience as well right yeah i'm pretty
curious to see how that shakes out i
imagine the licensing issues for like
combining something like this not that
it's their first rodeo but it just must
be a nightmare because both parties want
creative say over it despite the fact
that capcom is the one developing it
it's gonna there's all these shows all
these movies just expect those like
don't be shocked if you see like black
panther daredevil
black widow
you know so
yeah so like punisher like see when you
name all these and i'm thinking of these
like i liked the first season of
daredevil i haven't watched luke cage
yet
like i wonder if like jessica jones will
be in here or something don't you want
these characters drinks whiskey and
punches people don't you want these
characters to look like the comic book
version of these of their characters
like if you saw the t the the punisher
that we know from like modern media
i would jane yeah i don't know i don't
even follow that often but i would feel
a little bit betrayed to not see the
punisher that i knew growing up yeah but
i mean it'd be probably more that than
the tv show i guess i mean i hope so
you're you're right you resemble the
movie or the tv show what's marvel doing
really yeah like they're just disgracing
their current effort well that's the
thing i would imagine like iron fist is
going to show up because his show is
coming out soon i it's i'm worried
because when marvel vs capcom 3
was released this mcu like road map was
not in place there exactly there were a
few movies i think iron man had been out
by then the first thor maybe i can't i
can't remember which movies were out but
now there's i think there's two a year
two marvel movies a year seems like
spring fall and now
again how much is this just gonna be
marketing push for marvel's efforts some
of those characters technically like
even iron fist was already in three yeah
and thor was in three iron man i was in
three but iron man's been in a lot of
them like since the like way beginning
so like that's not too weird you didn't
say deadpool can't be included he's not
yeah he's [ __ ] i'm pretty sure all
right well wasn't spiderman sony for a
while but now
i think he's in marvel has it back
because he's yeah marvel got spider-man
back spider-man's like too big you know
yeah so on that note i'd love to see
carnage he hasn't made any of the games
any of these fighting games only venom
has so like uh jeremy renner's hawkeye
it's useless for most of the move uh
game
no just kidding hawkeye was pretty good
in three out of our games just saying
man all right well unless there's any
other points i think we've exhausted the
capcom marvel discussion but yeah so we
will see this weekend uh we have a
couple people uh justin sorry not justin
uh jake decker randy and uh some people
are going down to psx doesn't matter who
yeah going on psx which is in anaheim
this year as opposed to san francisco
like it was last year but we will have
more news out of there like likely we
will see marvel vs capcom 4 and we'll
have
more to talk about once we see that
announcement so leave your thoughts in
the comments below what kind of
characters you want to see which do you
think won't appear and what are your
overall thoughts about potential for
marvel vs capcom 4
all right i'm going to boot you off in a
second uh all right i've been playing
lately there's a lot of games out me i
haven't really uh i was playing
overcooked with my girlfriend that was
fun like it worked out
uh and i'm debating final fantasy 15. i
don't know if i want to
you know pour the hours into it but i
was just watching someone play a dungeon
and i was like oh that looks like fun
dungeons are freaking rad they're dark
they're spooky
difficult all right save final fantasy
15. sorry eric i'm going to boot you off
yeah final fantasy 15. bringing robert
he's falling asleep on the coffee table
over there roboto uh get his entrance
going on how are you
in case you didn't hear that's rob
hanlery
hi
the people listening to this are very
confused right now why is he not talking
why is he screaming i don't know what
he's going for oh
brought you on uh for a few segments
you have been playing a few games lately
first before we get into the nomad sky
update which will be our next segment i
want to talk about
the best open world games this year
because when i first thought of the
segment or like a few of us were
brainstorming we thought there were more
than there actually were i feel like
there's always at least like 10 open
world games every year but there
actually weren't a ton this year and i
think like between watchdog 2 releasing
very recently and final fantasy 15 uh
just releasing today it's kind of a good
time to touch on it i want to talk about
our favorites what do we think the best
was i think we all kind of picked one
out to mainly talk about but i'll touch
on all of them pete brown yeah which one
uh which one are you thinking of the
best and i mean sorry just to clarify i
mean in like a traditional sandbox open
world as opposed to like dark souls 3
which you have to like fast travel at
certain points and there's like certain
gates that you can't get through for a
while and it's very segmented i'm
talking like sandbox games like yeah
it's it's very difficult for me to
choose for me it comes down to no man's
sky watch dogs 2 or final fantasy 15. uh
all for very different reasons
uh which is why it's so hard to say the
best i will say my favorite right now
having played watch dogs 2 and final
fantasy 15 recently between those two
is final fantasy xv
um both games offer a lot of discovery
like if you spend your time really
digging around you'll find things that
are really surprising and
entertaining in some some cases but
uh really for me i think it's yeah it's
15.
um
just because of the the scale of
progression like you i'm 65 hours in and
i can still see another 10 or 15 hours
worth of things that i want to find and
explore uh and unlike something like no
man's sky you know
i know what i'm working towards in 15
i love no man's sky for its spectacle
and and a few other reasons but at the
end of the day after i met atlas i was
kind of like well
i've got better things to do with my
time
yeah and we will get into final fantasy
15 way more later in this show today but
i do think it's interesting because i
think it's i'd make it known i've never
played a final fantasy game before and i
just bought this last night i'm going to
be playing tonight
uh it's weird that the allure of a final
fantasy is that it's a pure open world
now as opposed to like the characters
and the storyline which you said were
serviceable and again not to critique
this too much until we get into the ass
reviewer section later but it is odd
that i'm getting into a final fantasy
because of its like you know gorgeous
sprawling pure open world sandbox yeah i
mean but that's you know that is sort of
the flavor of the month right or
the generation as it were i mean we saw
metal gear solid go open world final
fantasy is following and you know a lot
of games are sort of shifting how they
they handle
their traditions and putting it in a
modern package um so i can i think i can
relate to how that is interesting even
as a final fantasy fan that has me
stoked so i can see for someone who has
never played the series before how that
would tip them over into buying the game
i guess yeah just seeing it from a
distance it looks gorgeous which isn't
always like the biggest selling point
obviously but it does seem like there's
enough to like keep you pulling you from
region to region and these like late
game dungeons and missions and like
bosses and legendary weapons sound like
they'd be worth exploring for
of the three that you mentioned peter do
you think
um
if you were to pick one to be the most
repetitive because that's like one of my
biggest
burnouts
it's like oh like i've been kind of
doing this it's no man's sky
yeah usually yeah yeah i mean watch dogs
2 is
set in a city in san francisco that has
a lot of natural variety and that game
represents it very well you have a lot
of different activities that you can
involve yourself in
and 15 is kind of the same way
really combat and discovery are the two
main things um but yeah for for no man's
sky it was so repetitive to have to
constantly you know grind for resources
and ultimately to take the next step
time and time again and just repeat that
cycle and keep it going like that that
was super repetitive for me
yeah that was me last night
until very very late just like wait
and that i feel like that can get
deceiving too with some like no man's
sky where you still have those cool like
spectacle moments like occasionally like
when you do find that cool planet or
like
that
like enjoyable and
like like
tasteful animal to look at and that's
some just like hideous freak of nature
that you're just like come on
this thing
something straight up like the early
drawing boards of the last guardian that
they thought you might be like wandering
around that world with it's supposed to
trico now i think what i mean i've
showed you guys that that one animal
one animal that i showed you guys that's
like got these wings and it's this huge
like what is that like come on i can't
wait for the gif of that no that's just
me
we got a preview monitor here and it's
just me uh yeah uh
for me i suppose division was
one of my
um picks simply
just for that uh tone and that aesthetic
of that city
was super
like
i would say original right like you know
you think about like a gta or like watch
dogs like there's such a
lightheartedness where it's just
you know those moment to moments of just
like some crazy event happening but this
game division was like that's messed up
this one makes me think when i see
someone innocent civilian just getting
civilian just getting like
beat the hell up if or if i can't save
them in time they die
like you there's a guilt and there's
just like a
it's scary it's a scary game and that
was like very different for like of the
lineup i feel like for this yeah i mean
we've talked about a few times in the
lobby between like uh being like ptr
servers and just actually recent release
the survival mode now uh i think i've
said this a lot but this is one game i
only put two hours into back in march
when it released and i've been wanting
to play it ever since because from what
i played it was the world that was
drawing me in and again we've talked
about this before this is deja vu but
now that survival mode is out a lot of
people are saying
again this world makes more sense now as
an open world because it's a very risk
reward do i want to spend a lot of time
here even though the blizzard's going to
eventually freeze me to death if i don't
get to a fuel drum uh i need food i need
water i'm not going to be able to aim
and kill these harder enemies if i'm too
thirsty i need better gear do i want to
venture off the beaten path even though
i know this way is safe yeah i i really
i again i keep saying it but once i
finish all the other games like the
current games i want to get back to the
division that was like one of mine like
i don't know that it's the best and i
don't know it's my favorite because i've
only put two hours into it but it's the
most alluring to me in terms of its
aesthetic and its overall world design
yeah and i think i don't know when you
could date it back for open world games
but for me i remember fallout 4 having
that uh impact with like the surviving
mode like the game felt
natural and at its core and i feel like
i think far far cry primal did that i
never got into that version
but uh division seems like a perfect
place uh to have that like you i mean
why else is there i guess you have perks
associated with like water bottles and
soda cans and division but it's night
it's nice to like know that like that's
actually something that you are looking
for like heavily they are just like you
know goodies to sprinkle in yeah you did
just talk about far cry primal and
that's actually one that i'm not
surprised we haven't talked about a lot
it's just like it's the far cry 3 far
cry 4 2 to some extent formula implanted
on you know the stone age and but when i
reviewed it and when i played it i
actually really liked that game i was
really impressed that ubisoft
didn't kind of eventually just give you
like this machine gun rock thrower or
this like this electric spear or
anything
it stayed pretty grounded aside from
like the mystical elements but it stayed
grounded in this world and you just
mentioned that they released that uh
update afterward that added the like a
survival mode i did play a little bit of
it and i again like you said with
fallout 4 and even with the division i
think that's the way to play this game
when you know like in the base game when
night fell and when like the sun went
down that's when a lot of the predators
would come out fires were good for
warding off like wolves and whatnot but
now apparently you know there's cold to
maintain which is in the first game or
the base game as well but it just became
way more dangerous in survival mode
which is what i liked about the base
game did you did you guys even play a
lot of far cry primal yeah
i played a good amount and you know just
like many games i think uh
can fall victim to that
you just get too overpowered and i think
survival works so well for open world is
giving you that that
that strong incentive to make that
weapon to go like to be on the cusp of
dying you know and i think far cry is a
perfect example of like
making a spear like that's like you know
bow and arrow is the first thing you
make like that's pretty much survival
like
uh it fits well there and you know i
just realized even no man's sky
did that with this new update i haven't
tried it yet though but
yeah it's just interesting it's just
like making incentive and making you
feel uncomfortable i think is something
appealing and you know then to look back
50 hours in like dang i i got out of
that rut like
i don't know it's more empowering yeah
it is weird because again i think the
game was pretty forgettable against that
far cry formula that we've kind of come
to know and maybe get sick of um but
looking back it is actually one of my
like favorite open world experiences
this year although i haven't played
final fantasy yet but to continue
talking about ubisoft which now that i
say it out loud they had three open most
of the games in this list are ubisoft
titles yeah um obviously they have
different studios all over the world but
watch dogs too we kind of touched on um
living here in san francisco i think was
the main allure of that game before it
came out i did not like the first
watchdogs some of the problems i had
with the first watch dogs carried over
to this one
i played about four or five hours of
watch dogs two
uh p.e reviewed it but i still felt like
it was kind of lifeless i know it's
tough to have enough people in a city in
a game to make it feel like it's really
vibrant and kind of just like pulsating
like i want it to and i was exploring
san francisco just to see some of the
sights the tourist attractions uh see if
you could find
like our office or my neighborhood
neither of which were in the game but
you reviewed it what like
what do you think about the world itself
as it functions like as an open world
game um
you're 100 correct like lifeless
is an adjective that applies i think to
a degree right like there are not that
many people on the street there is not
that many cars on the road there's
enough to kind of give you those
variables to at least consider but yeah
it doesn't feel like san francisco in
that respect but
the open world i think
uh benefited from again what i was
saying earlier like the variety that
exists within it the visual variety the
terrain variety
um and the terrain being urban and
natural i thought there was a very very
good mix of those two
so
in terms of the open world being alive
i don't know that that was necessarily
the case but i felt alive in that open
world damn oh [ __ ] yeah profundity
yeah i don't know rob you live in san
francisco
lee our cameraman is trying not to laugh
at that
sick
sick comment no i should be fired for
that i'm gonna buy that game now did you
but did you play a lot of watchdogs too
rob i didn't i haven't played any okay
unfortunately um
uh yeah it's just i think this time
around you know this year as they say is
like has been just an influx of really
awesome shooters it's kind of been where
my mind
uh i think has been after like i feel
like i've just been burned out and
exhausted over the last few years of
open world games where it's like just
you know even when it came out like i
was playing dayz like the first year i
ever started game supply and like
those
those games i can't do anymore because
they just kill me like
oh man it's 4am and i haven't seen [ __ ]
like i
i mean that's your extreme game but like
uh i'm a little afraid to play watchdogs
too just because i i um i'm afraid of
the moment where like
i see that uh really funny i keep
hearing about this uh gameplay moment
where you're walking around it's like
someone freaking out and beating up a
car yeah but i've heard that
from many people so i'm wondering when
like hmm when is that going to be the
third time or fourth time that i've just
kind of experienced that uh you know i
have to say like you know you compare
that to like the five years for gta
like
that shows like i still tuned into that
game once a while and i'm like oh i
don't think i've ever heard that yeah
and that is where it's just like i don't
know it's it's super hard to top that
type of world i will say the one thing
that watch dogs 2 offers is a very easy
way to get strangers either near or far
to like share a piece of themselves with
you by stealing that piece from them
right by reading their text messages or
listening in on their phone calls yeah
and there are some funny anecdotes in
there like it's not the to the same
caliber of what you get in gta because
you're not it's not an organic
experience it is something you have to
like
trigger right and again it is just
something very quick and then it's gone
but
i will say that in its defense there is
a lot of character buried within that
world you have to go just a little bit
farther to get to it and that's where
the first one fell short right like you
had
those text messages or like those uh
just i don't know bios right but they
were like three words or like four words
like who cares you're like what is that
of value but yeah when i hear that
that's pretty cool like yeah we had any
kind of story sorry yeah we haven't been
on any crazy dumb tangents yet today so
here's mine uh have you seen the movie
bedazzled
way back in the day is it a documentary
about adding gemstones no no no it's uh
brendan fraser fraser and jennifer my
fifth one sorry elizabeth hurley is it
really your fifth favorite no it's
number one of course
come on this is useless and almost a
non-sequitur but at the beginning of
that movie i forget how it fits into the
themes of the movie but they do that
they show this like bio of someone
hovering above them
i don't even know how it fits into the
rest of the movie now that i think out
loud but when i first played the first
watch dogs i thought of brandon frazier
and elizabeth hurley and bedazzled
anyway the last one i wanted to talk
about was dlc uh witcher 3 blood and
wine sure we'll bring it up because it's
an entirely new area that you explore uh
it's like it's a new region it's kind of
like this french like uh toussaint it's
you know like french dialect kind of
spoken there um
you put some time into this oh and i was
on a roll
yeah what she's what oh oh she's talking
oh mary through
bedazzled so there we go
oh gee yeah let's vamp oh there's go
ahead mike even in san francisco so
watch dogs 2 and
a lot of segways this is crazy
environmental ubisoft you're ripping off
bedazzled no i'm just kidding uh here's
a here's for those listening mary just
threw up the intro that i was talking
about yeah this one guy double dips this
person
uh a lot of watch dogs dubai there he is
brendan fraser's love sick ex dog
walking walking down market street he's
desperate oblivious eager to please this
is blowing this makes sense
holy [ __ ] i kind of when i first started
talking about i was like this is the
worst tangent ever but now i actually
like it seems like i had a plan the
whole time i think you just unearthed
the secret to watchdog
they didn't have the guts to just
completely rip it off so they set the
first one in chicago like we'll get
we'll get to san francisco in the sequel
anyway doormat he's a
all right bites his toenails
so toussaint
in the wizard three blood and wines
entirely new like open world segment
it's this like uh french speaking
kind of more stable environment than the
base game the base games uh world was
kind of you know in the middle of a
civil war uh rob blood and wine did you
play
yeah i really liked it a lot and i was
like uh on a roll playing that game um
and then had you know we go through a
lot of games here so you have to like
put things down but
yeah and that that felt like witcher
3.5 it just it just felt like a whole
it i think it was probably like the best
deals i mean it's one of my favorites it
was like one of the best dlcs i think of
the year uh just because like there was
just so much going on and that is a
living breathing world for the most part
just for the amount of quests and
characters you are constantly meeting
uh you know it's it's a game where like
you can't do it all uh and that says a
lot i mean i think you know you could
say the same for like fallout as well
but
just like
the change of uh
tone and heart for witcher you know yeah
you had a civil war with like just
saying you know not genocide but like
tons of casualties in a war like in the
mud like just dead and here's just
really
like chirpy uh french town like sunsets
and just gorgeous like uh locales like
it was a cool way to close out that game
cd projekt red is as they've proven time
and time again are really good at
telling these open world stories that
these things you just stumble upon but
also these things that tie different
regions of the open world together and
kind of
give you a reason to explore beyond just
like new weapons or gear just actually
uncovering these really well-written
tangential stories uh i didn't get to
play much blood and wine this year
unfortunately i played hearts of stone
last year which was a really good
expansion that was more linear you're
going to places within the original base
games world and now that blood and wine
is out i think the witcher 3 is even
more of a you know high bar for open
world games and i had a cool time with
uh hearts and songs because i actually
didn't get a chance to play when it came
out so what you could do is actually
play them both at the same time
i don't think i've ever done this with
dlc before uh i guess yeah i can't
remember if i have but anyways going
back and forth between
worlds like you know in hearthstone you
you know
spoiler you get like a scar from a guy
on your face and he's like i won't
remove it remove it until you do
something so i'm going around like
tucson with a scar in my face like i
don't think people react to it but like
it was just kind of interesting to be
like man i should probably get the scar
off my face like just multitasking i
don't know i just felt cool to like go
back and forth between like as you said
like really awesome
uh well-rounded stories it was just fun
to like have that freedom uh yeah i
don't remember how you get that scar
removed there's like a laser surgeon in
the swamp or something
what's that the man of glass it was a
joke but i forget how you get the scar
off your face yeah the the
that dude gauntero dim the guy that was
a hell of a villain did he come back in
blood and wine or is that a spoiler or
do you even know
there's this there was this really cool
like arch character that they introduced
in a hearthstone that
i thought they were laying the
groundwork for later stories uh i don't
know uh
if anybody in the chat knows if you
played blood and wine let me know if
gontoro dim is back but anyway those
were the you know the major open world
games like most of which were ubisoft
titles and some of which may have ripped
off a 90s movie or two
um agreed yeah so
yeah now that i have final fantasy 15
i'm gonna try to get into that tonight
and i will have played most of these
games this year but anyway let us know
if we missed any that you want us to
mention let us know what your favorites
are and
what next movie ubisoft should rip off
all right rob i'm about to kick you off
but
what are you playing tonight you're
still doing no more guys
i'm not kicking you off no no no sorry
we're still talking about uh one that we
just touched on actually
uh i want to talk about no man's sky
cool
the huge update sorry i don't know why i
almost did that i just it's okay get so
uh so sick of you on the set i'm kidding
uh yeah so no man's sky major update
just released uh lee couple days ago
uh yeah absolutely um and you were
playing quite a lot of it yesterday last
night uh
tell us about it what are the major
features that it does and overall i kind
of want to know if it makes the game
better yeah
uh we'll kind of i'll have to like get
to that later because i have a hard time
um
kind of coming to that conclusion like i
definitely think it is a
i mean it is what it is like it's a cool
name because it it definitely like laid
some groundwork and it made it easier
for me to actually see
you know if they and i
hope they continue to like improve this
game you can kind of see where they're
going um
but essentially yeah you i mean it
starts off and i think it caters to how
a lot of people got frustrated with the
game was like
it just feels like you know we talked
about open world like games where it's
just getting repetitive and i'm not
seeing
um enough diversity in these planets
that's worthwhile uh so you have three
different game modes right you have your
normal one so your save is unaffected uh
and then you have uh creative i'll get
to that and then like survival so it's
like kind of like almost like uh
as far as like time length goes like
long play short play and like you know
normal mode um
but you get base building which is
where the game was lacking was i feel uh
direction in some form where it was like
i don't really know what i'm supposed to
be doing at some point you know you get
to a point you kind of hit atlas uh if
you chose that path and then it's like
i don't know what i'm supposed to be
making i i there were times on a planet
where it's like what was i doing i
forget and it's hard to pull up
you know just that waypoint yeah uh and
so the game basically lets you create
your own base
create your own base you then bring in
uh a specialist so you actually the game
implements more uh npc aliens on space
station so i go up i grab a um
[Music]
one of these guys i say work for me my
base and then he starts basically giving
me almost like side quests that are
directing me towards which is i think
the heart of the game
the lack thereof is just basically
technology and uh like a minecraft game
you're just building and crafting so
he's just giving me those and he's
saying you need a weapon specialist so
now i'm building basically a little
society in my own base as well as i'm um
that first guy is still also giving me
um new materials to use so now i can
oppose to like the prefab circular
um buildings i can now kind of go out
and do whatever i want with blocks and
then i can make towers and i can do all
these things
so that's pretty cool i think that's um
very minecraft and almost reminds me of
like factorio in a good way where like
it gives more drive
to
um
be effective and be efficient and it's
more clearly laid out
um it almost reminds me of fallout 4 as
well like a lot of i didn't use the base
building in fallout 4 as much and they
introduced in skyrim too with uh the
figure what the dlc was called you could
build a house uh i feel like it's meant
to root people more in this universe
because after a while you know like with
infinite planets how do you get attached
to any one right build a base on it
right like a home to return to did you
feel that now like do you actually kind
of like going back here and stuff is
this like the new drive for you to play
this game
yeah i i think i'll play some more of it
because i i haven't really come
i would say
um i'm afraid of coming to that burnout
phase but
uh i see longevity because
you know um
i mentioned the base building you can
then get a freighter and these actually
i think are the coolest right they're
like the coolest part of the game that
like gives me that spectacle back or add
spectacle to this game where uh
eventually you amount to like you know i
think the cheapest one is like seven mil
that i saw for like a freighter i can
then land my smaller craft on the
freighter and offload supplies
and essentially the idea being like um
okay this is instead of me if i'm doing
trade routes i'm trying to like you know
get into the marketplace in a different
solar system i can make a base there and
and come back to that go to a different
solar system you know get a commodity
just offload tons of stuff onto my
freighter which you can also customize
to degree like your base
put storage units in there i can get um
there's also like i'll get it later but
yeah you basically can just offload more
and more uh items onto these freighters
and then this overhaul tons and tons of
stuff
and that's neat and it's it's a cool
spectacle to just like be on any planet
any place and just hit this hologram of
like where do you want your freighter to
go and it just warps in
and you can like just go up to it and
just like i don't know diving down off
of it into a planet like gave me these
vibes of like aliens when they like
first do that drop or like even call of
duty like
because that's my favorite part of the
game i think for sure is entering a
planet is just like it's dramatic it's
so dramatic yeah and even leaving it
like hits the synth music you know like
um
it brings back that and i and i
that was what i first uh really really
liked about the game
um
but uh one more side note of like
another really big one is like uh more
um
uh quality of life stuff so you have
like a hot you're not looking at a menu
nearly as often which is like oh man my
um launch pads need plutonium all right
great i gotta go in this menu you can do
that real quickly uh with this new kind
of hot menu thing which is like bam bam
bam you just throw it in um and the
other thing is which is really big is
say i land on a planet
and i can't find [ __ ] because it's
barren they give you basically like the
ability to throw down a um a device that
will save the game another one that will
basically beam out and search for those
quests you know may they be find
a abundance of resource or a colonial
outpost or etc so
it's just it's just quality of life uh
uh raised like you just can find things
easier to go back to the bases quick you
might have said this so correct me but
can you just build these anywhere you
want on any planet so that's that's why
you have this device perfect timing here
as you set this up and then one of the
options is find me a hat um
habitable bass okay
and then that's where i can basically go
in and it's like do you want to set up
camp here and make this your home world
okay and i have that option
and then that links to any kind of space
station
so i could go as far as i want like in
the solar system uh our galaxy and then
uh always be able to come back to that
base but once you establish that base it
stays there you can't have it right in
one of those bases unless you're in a
different playthrough
i think
is that even made clear yet i don't know
i haven't been able to do multiple bases
but freighters you can only have one
okay just like it i think it's very
similar to your uh spaceship i think you
just kind of wipe whatever you had
before however everything you had as far
as items will be transfer transferred
over so you're not really like at loss
other than like whatever time you spend
into the structure okay so overall i
mean you played no man's sky when it
released p you played a lot too you
reviewed it
that's right
rob did you do you think this improves
it sounds like this improves the game
overall uh is it worth returning to now
like i guess that's a pretty subjective
question but does this make you
personally wanna return to it a lot more
are you gonna be playing a lot tonight
or no
personally it makes me it does make me
wanna uh play some more of it um
but
i think
it's not quite there yet i'd like to see
more things like having thought about
the freighter like the freighter is so
cool it's like i think it's a really
cool idea yet
you know you get attacked by space space
pirates i'm like oh cool maybe i can
send in this freighter which i know has
guns on it and i i warp him in he
doesn't do anything
like it'd be cool to have that fleet or
like build up in that respect like a
fleet because when you first pick the
freighter he is in like a whole group of
like other ships
um
it would be
really cool
you know to basically have these huge
like
war uh space battles right like just
like like bombarding other ships like
huge conflicts in space there's not
enough of that i think that could be
like what would drive me in and it would
make me want to like upgrade my ship or
a crew or whatever it is i don't know i
do feel like that's the next step i
think they can do it yeah josh shaw on
the twitch chat was saying shouldn't
this be focused on building ships i
wonder if that is like a step down the
road i know they maybe they think they
they think they hinted at that or
someone found i think some file in the
actual game of that i believe well that
would make sense i mean having these
bases that you can build on a planet
kind of roots you in one and makes you
like care about that planet more whereas
building a new ship you can take that
wherever you go and that like seems to
draw the scheme the spectacle of
discovering new star systems new you
know galaxies new planets and whatnot i
feel like i would rather build a ship
that i can take with me i mean like
obviously the freighters you can but
like in terms of the one i'm flying i
would like to put like try out pete have
you
do you see yourself you like this game
you enjoyed it you think you gave a
seven
do you see yourself returning to this at
all no
just you you've had it you're full of
knowing this guy no i uh so all these
things that you're describing like they
sound great and like they sound like
things that i would love to have had
access to when the game came out right
totally that's how i feel uh you know
when i was first playing my mentality
was follow atlas because i found that
path to be fulfilling from like a
narrative perspective right like this
the things i was working towards was
working towards a conclusion of my own
story
well if my story that i'm making now is
just to build things for myself to
marvel at that
that's two that's too shallow for me
just because i don't get a lot out of i
think um just base building just for the
sake of it right like even fallout 4
even though you had people like npcs
that were walking around that would
change as you did that i didn't really
get what the ultimate goal was like how
was i rewarded was it just the
creativity behind it it kind of seemed
to be the case and that may be true here
as well
um
i need some greater purpose for all of
this stuff i need to feel like what i'm
doing has meaning
beyond just i can do this now and look
what i made yeah you can introduce as
many features as you want but at one
point are they still cohesive with like
the overall meaning of the game
yeah and like you know
what are the challenges involved with
building right like
sure there are
time and endurance based challenges
where you need to get enough resources
to do the thing
but are there intellectual challenges
they're in like do things become more
difficult to build or manage or are you
literally just scaling up and making
things bigger because you have more of
the stuff that you need to do that if
that's all it is then yeah i just
i don't have any to go back i still
cherish the first you know
god 60 70 hours i spent with that game
but um beyond that i think i i don't
know that this update will bring me in
again
sure yeah yeah i would just tap on that
like yeah i totally agree and like i'm
still kind of in that
that spectacle
phase of just like this is still pretty
cool looking i'm like getting these huge
freighters
uh space battles like you know i wish i
could see more of but yeah at the end of
the day i i this is how the first yeah
uh play i had with that game ended and
like even last night
playing until i was like 3am 4am i'm
like wait what am i doing actually right
now right
and that when that hit me i was like
i've seen this and so you know what it
always is though it's when i see like
the god damn same freaking plant when i
see that plant i've seen him i've seen
him on every planet when i see him
i'm out that's it you liar dumb animal
how is this plan on every planet get out
of here plant you know
we found something that's not no sleep
yeah all right you've been playing too
much no man's sky
but you're gonna play a little go play
somewhere yeah anyway so that is no
man's sky newest update is live now on
all platforms you can play that ps4 pc
it's all the way live yeah cool so let
us know if you plan on returning no
man's sky now this update is out
all right rob thanks for coming on i'm
actually kicking off this time cool
thanks for having me everyone have a
great day see ya bye i don't know where
the sarcasm came from
i can't get anything genuine we're gonna
bring jake deckard on right now i just
called you jake deckard jake decker
what's my name uh you've been playing a
lot of final fantasy xv
yeah not as much as peter but i've been
playing a lot of it pete you reviewed it
it's finally time for the segment that
i'm sure a lot of people are waiting for
ask the reviewer we want to get into
your review of the game 10 years in the
making
my review was 10 years in the making yes
your review
you just submitted draft after draft for
the past 10 years they gave them a
review copy 10 years ago
super advanced copy
uh all right pete let's dive into it you
gave it an 8 out of 10. you like this
game a lot tell me about it what's good
about it what's good about it uh
well
let me start with what i think was
disappointing so i can actually set up
what is really good about it because i
think that's important to understand
um as i said in the beginning of my
review a lot of final fantasy games are
remembered fondly for their story and
their characters i
did not find anything in this game that
struck me as memorable or original or
[Music]
that surprising like i feel like i've
you know i've seen these stereotypes
before like the you know the the main
cast that you're rolling around with um
i've seen villains like we we've seen uh
in in the past and even some of the
events in the game seem somewhat
derivative of our favorite final fantasy
games and that's
that to me is is um is kind of
disappointing like there is sort of the
spectacle of the story missions and
certain boss battles that are these you
know huge bombastic scenes that that
really just showcase what made modern
final fantasy games uh special for i
think a mainstream audience just you
know if i can generalize that way
and that stuff is fun but
by the time you're done with the story
i was left thinking like
all right i don't really know that i
even care about what just happened
because what lay ahead of me was a world
that i had felt like i had only just
begun to tap into now the story you can
finish in as little as 10 to like 12
hours japanese players are doing it that
fast right now like hitting level 35 and
being done with the game i spent a
little more time to meet the recommended
level caps and it took me just about 30
hours a little bit more
but since then i have played 35 hours
just exploring the world to
finish side quests but not just for the
sake of finishing them but to
to in effect grind so i can get to the
high level stuff that i found just
wandering around the world like you find
crazy difficult dungeons you find huge
monsters and all you can think about is
man someday i will be able to get to the
bottom of that dungeon or defeat that
monster and see what i get as a reward
or even see what i am capable of as a
player in this world
and it's those pursuits long term that
kept me going and keep me going um
i have two
major optional quest lines left that are
promising to give me the best of
everything that i want out of this world
which is
equipment and
crazy battles and some of the dungeons i
was looking through a strategy guide
today to solve a mystery that i hadn't
been able to solve up until this point
turns out the solution is somewhat easy
but
the dungeons that i will be seeing are
insane the strategy guide said we can't
explain this to you in text and image
format we've prepared a video because
this dungeon is
so hard to interpret
and not not just because it's a maze but
because dimensions angles all these
things get with you like the fifth
dimension
yeah
just escape the amount of time and space
uh it's no but so anyway i just think
like this game has a lot of faults and
you know it's the cliched statement
applies it is more than a sum of its
parts like
i can complain about a lot but i can
also gush
twice as much about smaller details
yeah we touched on it earlier in the
show we were talking about open world
games this year and i was saying as
someone who's never played a final
fantasy or final fantasy game but is
gonna jump into it with 15 tonight i
never really think of the
open world aspects of this game because
this is like one of the first times it's
been like just pure sandbox almost
sandbox yeah like the way i define it is
like you know contemporary open world
principles or what applied here because
a lot of final fantasy games you know
apart from some gatekeeping you do have
access to a massive world and you can go
out there and find towns and some people
will give you these tiny quests but the
way that this game handles it is much
more similar to something you'd see from
ubisoft right or
um you know similar studio publishers
yeah yeah jake you've been playing a lot
too and you were saying like you're
you've been taking it really slowly
exploring these
like these regions and whatever yeah eos
the content so i actually kind of had a
question about the story i guess do you
think you may have liked it more though
if you took it slower because i'm going
slow and i'm finding out like there's a
lot of like side conversations you have
with characters like do you think you
might like the characters more if you're
moving slower because i'm taking my time
and so it's not that i didn't
necessarily like the characters but i
don't think that they are remarkable in
any sense okay um like prompto for
example is a very sort of like you know
uplifting personality to be around like
you know you you win a difficult battle
and
like he sings like the classic final
fantasy victory song and that's like
very charming like you know i like that
and
but you know like i look at ignis and i
look at gladio specifically
ignis is oh i'm british and i wear
glasses so i must be the smart one in
the group you know like
like are we idiots are we supposed to
look at that and say man that's a really
clever take on a character i've never
seen before and now there are times
where these characters get a moment in
the spotlight to show a different side
of themselves
but again those don't feel like they
warrant any like serious acclaim from me
so i think like
there is some charm to to gain by
spending time with these characters but
by the end of the story when you've seen
everything that they have to say and
they begin repeating themselves and
you've seen all the story moments that
they're involved with
you're left wondering wait a minute they
showed me the side of them that i didn't
see before and then it went away then
they went back to the same person they
were and i got nothing new out of them
it just felt like a very fabricated
artificial
uh moment yeah before i actually came in
here i had an interaction with prompto
it was like one of the hotels or
whatever and it was like a lot deeper
than normal because normally like you're
saying like we go into a battle and he's
singing or he's like oh this is fun or
whatever but then right after that it's
back in a battle and he's like chipper
again even though he just had this sort
of deep conversation with noctis exactly
yeah it's it's surprising i think when
you look back i'm just i feel like i'm
reiterating so much my review i
apologize for those who've read it but
if you if you look back at you know like
some of the best characters in the
history of final fantasy games were your
sidekicks we're the supporting cast
because they they not only offered
something very different from the main
character but very different from people
we know in the real world right and i
feel like so much what we look at here
are stereotypes we've seen in media and
stereotypes that get
that are based on like real world people
in some sense if that makes sense that's
a bit of a stretch but
well yeah i don't know after reading a
review and talking to you a lot about
this again because this is going to be
my first final fantasy and i'm pretty
excited to try it out but
you said like the first 30 hours or so
or like you said some people are being
like 15 but probably like 25 30 hours is
fun because you're going through the
main story you're seeing eos this
continent um yeah but you also said that
like the late gate late game content
these massive bosses
um these dungeons these legendary
weapons that's where you had the most
fun i believe or where you had a lot of
the fun like can you talk about that
late game stuff like if we stick around
for like 60 70 hours like you did what
can we expect to see so one of the
things you do in the story it's an
initiative it's an effort that you start
is you have to go reclaim these weapons
that belong to former kings your your
forefathers right and you find
five or six of them throughout the story
and then but if you keep just following
it
you can finish the game with only that
many right so that'll leave a whole
bunch you need to find well how do you
get to them where are they in the world
right so that not only requires a little
bit of digging
um but it requires you to i think uh
take the time to do side quests because
you figure out early on that side quests
maybe the goal itself is kind of trite
but the place it takes you
teases you like you'll come across
you'll go fight this little guy and
you're like wait what's that thing just
over the horizon i've never seen that
before right and it's not until you go
into that side quest you see that really
cool thing so the late game stuff is a
process of
finishing the stuff you didn't do during
the story and then realizing like man
this world is more fascinating than i
thought and so these these end game
dungeons are like most of the dungeons
in the game pitch black the only thing
that you can see
is whatever is illuminated by your
flashlight
or maybe an enemy appears and the
glowing behind their eyes would like you
know light up in the dark and it's that
sort of like feeling of this like
daunting adventure
and
as you improve and as you begin to beat
these big things that's when i kind of
began to like my my team a bit more
because it definitely felt at this point
that like they were my
they you know we were fighting a battle
together i didn't care about their
personalities so much as i valued what
they brought into a fight yeah um and
that's that's how i found value in them
and i thought that they each offered
something very different so it's it's
both a personal personally gratifying
thing to be able to beat this late game
stuff but also find a way to actually
appreciate the characters that you're
rolling with i do want to touch on the
combat because you said that was a high
point of the game and it looks fun from
everything i've been seeing yes what do
you want to touch on about uh can you
just i don't know what do you think
about it for people who haven't read
your review like uh how does it work
because it's it's all like real time and
but you're still swapping between party
members if you want to right no not at
all oh really yeah so actually what you
saw was you can use what are they called
the special moves i guess is what they
are and then it swaps that character and
you watch them that's what i saw they're
sort of like limit breaks like you have
a meter that has three bars as your
teammates attack and i think it even
builds gradually over time you can spend
certain amounts of that meter to command
your teammates to do something that's
the only control you have over them in
battle so you'll you know and you can
only control one of those abilities at a
time you can't have a character with
multiple ones right so at any given
fight you have three possible commands
to issue your teammates but that's it
otherwise you're just controlling noctis
and it is uh if you you can choose to
have not real-time combat which i'll get
to in a second but for all intents and
purposes it's real-time combat you hold
down one button to just do a string of
attacks right there's no
real strategy behind when you attack but
you can
phase out of a phase from an enemy
attack so if they swing at you
if you're holding down square it'll just
pass right through you
um
that and the ability to throw your
weapon and warp to where it is or warp
attack an enemy from a distance that'll
cost magic points
you have to manage noctis's magic points
because when he runs out he's in a
weakened state so
basically what you're doing this whole
battle is attacking defending at the
right time
saving and regenerating magic points as
often as possible um
but a lot of the tougher battles you
have to use a lot of items there aren't
many uh
curative spells in this game like there
are no just plain curative spells
everything is either fire based
lightning based or ice based and you
have to cast that element and then have
a side effect maybe
so you use items a lot and to use items
you do slow you do stop combat you press
a button and it lets you go through a
menu
on the other hand there's also weight
mode which if you stop moving on the
battlefield the camera will stop and you
have lines between you and the end and
the various enemies on the field and you
can
take your time and pick which one you
want you know to target and do something
but that is just so arduous and it
totally removes like what is fun about
combat and actually you kind of lose
what is happening in the moment when you
stop to do that kind of sounds like it
sacrifices the flow that yeah like
real-time combat it sounds like it has
that's that's the way it felt for me and
i can see that they put it in there for
people who maybe are having difficulties
but there's also an easy mode which i
didn't try but from what i understand
it's basically you can't die
uh because your teammates can sort of
revive you you have like two death
states one is temporary one is permanent
uh and so i think your enemies probably
or your allies just revive you at that
point yeah you just mentioned easy mode
i did want to ask i mean it's an rpg so
the more you grind the easier it's gonna
be but
what's like the difficulty of this game
overall
um it's the story mode is pretty easy up
until i'd say the second to last
uh dungeon if you can call it that of
the story mode which has a the level
require or suggested level requirement
jumps pretty high
it's pretty easy but when you get into
the end game stuff very very tough i
mean i am expending
you know you find some really like crazy
restorative items in the world and i'm
sitting there like oh god i gotta use
this thing like i've only got two of
them after 60 hours but my party's dying
i'm on my last breath like the enemy is
so close to death
i'll use it uh and so it does get very
difficult towards the end um and
grinding is a thing but even then i'm
fighting enemies like once you get above
level 40
enemies at level 40 will still be
challenging even at level 60. so uh
yeah it's a hard game there's so much to
talk about i'm sorry i'm like yeah no
i've been rambling through it it sounds
huge and like especially just seeing
road trip across gameplay or something i
have no idea but uh it does sound like
after 10 years it was worth the wait you
liked it quite a bit
yeah i i
worth the wait i don't know that i'd say
that maybe 10 years is kind of a long
time but i'll be honest now that it's
here all of that is history i'm just
looking at the game as it is today i'm
not really like i i was never
emotionally invested in this game to
begin with i was always just curious
like what is it going to be so now i see
what it is and what it is is a great
game one that i think doesn't
necessarily live up to the
the series legacy in some ways but it
also reinvents it and does some new
things that it's never done before cool
i'm looking forward to playing it as my
first final fantasy but if you want to
hear more about it pete's full review is
up on gamespot he gave it an 8 out of 10
so go to gamespot.com and check that out
gonna do one more segment on final
fantasy 15 okay before we end the show
probably as long as that i'm sorry
i think people want to hear you
people
we were kind of like wondering uh what
people want to know about the game in
the long term uh i mean
once you get past this late game content
these dungeons these huge bosses you
maybe find all the legendary weapons
we're kind of wondering what people
might want out of it or like what we
personally might want out of it uh in
dlc down the stretch in 2017 or after
whenever they choose to keep supporting
the game until um but jake i don't know
you've been playing i think you said
about like
12 hours now around that yeah i think
i'm around 12 hours now i mean even like
from now from what you've heard from
pete and like about the late game
content can you think of anything that
you'd think this game should add or
maybe would just be like more of the
same late game cons that we have now
well i mean after hearing what peter was
saying about the those late game
dungeons and after like hearing what it
said in the guide i think
late game dungeons would be cool really
far down the road however i think right
now it would be nice to have more
customization options um i know the car
you can change colors you can add decals
right but i kind of don't like what any
of my characters are wearing
leather boys yeah and i think you can
like change some of them but i think i
also heard you say that you can't really
buy new stuff in the game so you're
stuck with your leather zippered up you
can't buy there's there's a whole
equipment menu for a tire and you can't
buy any yeah you start with like four
options for each right but there's two
outfits that have the option to put on a
jacket or not yeah so it's just let's be
honest it's just two so
are we assuming they are setting it up
for dlc in the future like that or like
maybe micro transactions i hope so like
what the hell
you're stuck with this dude showing off
his six-pack like his unzipped leather
yeah or you put him in like these like
white
chino pants and like a i don't know like
oh yeah
the options they blow they suck family
owns like a hotel in the florida keys
yeah like i'm okay with noctis i'm okay
with with prompto i guess but yeah
gladio and ignis i just found myself
like ugh and justin brought up a good
point justin haywald was like wait you
mean i can't wear classic final fantasy
gear like i don't get to find these like
red outfits and i was like no but that
sounds awesome like i would love to
dress prompto up like cloud yeah what do
you mean like perfect fit you know
there's there's so many of those
instances noctis could be squall if we
really wanted to go there don't the
outfits even like change attributes
slightly too they do it it seems kind of
weird to only have
two or four you so
you do at one point unlock another one
but it
sick one more one more right and i found
myself more caught up in the fact that i
hated the way my characters looked than
oh i like the way that this benefits my
stats
you know yeah i would i would pick
something that made me weaker because i
didn't have to stare at a dumb outfit
i do that yeah i would too yeah i do
that all the time like very super loud
like
so it's like these stats look better but
you look dumb with like a piece of metal
sticking out of here
so we're gonna you can give him new
earrings though
or this sick ski vest yeah like he looks
he looks like a rich person trying to
like fit in with commoners in that
outfit like yeah his clothes don't fit
he doesn't know how to wear a hat like
it's perfect for the desert too
yeah he looks like he'll he's not even
sweating at all all right so new
equipment and just accessories clothing
in general would be good beyond that
weapons merchants sell one or two
weapons like i i think for any character
the most weapons i have is like eight or
nine well cause you said like the late
game a lot of the cool parts of the lake
coming across these the legendary
weapons that your forefathers had well
sort of so those aren't
traditionally weapons those are super
powered and when you use them they drain
your hp so they're sort of like
something you use when you're feeling
very confident and you don't need to
worry but most of the time when you're
doing the high level stuff you can't use
them because it'll put you at a
disadvantage so you do use just standard
weapons but there is a quest line right
now that i've opened where i'm seeking a
different set of legendary weapons
um and those are actual like real ones
so i'm hoping to get those but it's just
one per per weapon type
i'm not finding like a suite of swords
that look rad or offer a lot of
different properties there are some
differences but
to go to a shop and just see one sword
the entire game is [ __ ] like yeah
because you like don't even really see
the see the swords and stuff unless
you're fighting like it almost seems
like why don't you just have more and
like not like yeah just
yeah like it pisses me off it's it's not
enough that i i think about it long term
but reflecting on it now it's like yeah
that is really dumb that is really super
bad like it doesn't hurt combat but it
hurts my ownership over my character
yeah in open world games especially rpgs
of this magnitude i kind of want to see
my character look different at the end
or at least like play different with
different weapons or something they do
look different at the end
but is it because of
equipment or outfits
no are you are you are we in spoiler
territory should i stop talking not
really okay but
if they become
okay it's it's it's it's like very
obvious foreshadowing in like
there's no question that it's
foreshadowing it's interesting but in
the sense that i would like to keep like
building my character with new gear and
whatnot throughout the game which i
don't i don't again i don't is that like
a final fantasy trope or no not like a
lot like um
in terms of changing appearance okay but
in terms of having a lot of options
yes that is if you want to call it trope
i call it you know yeah tradition
okay um something else that might be
kind of cool like i actually haven't
found any of the summons yet and it
seems like they're a pain in the ass to
actually sometimes sound like there's a
lot are there but it might be cool to
have more maybe there's four there's
four yeah you see you see more in the
game but you can only use four and if
you're lucky you will cast two of them
it's really they need yeah you didn't
you sounded pretty sour on the summit it
was one it was one of the bad notes on
the review one of the things that
definitely did stand out to me more than
the lack of swords which i you know
wasn't didn't feel egregious enough for
me to get that upset about in the big
picture but the summons oh my god the
game makes such a big deal about them
and you can never freaking cast them you
have to be at a certain like
health state in battle and in a certain
region
but that's [ __ ] even if you're in
those states in that place you can't
cast those freaking summons i was i knew
the rules i i was told to me by the
press the pr team
i spent an hour trying to summon
leviathan
it didn't happen didn't you have to be
near a lot yeah i was walking in near
water and
you're correct
your health was really low i went i went
to the
ocean coast i went on a lake i went on a
river and leviathan was somewhere else
just [ __ ] off
all i want for christmas the mariah
carey version yeah and so like you know
you get in these huge battles not when
not when you're just trying to summon
them right but in the game you're
getting these huge battles and in past
final fantasy games he'd be like you
know what i'm going to kick your ass
with ifrit right now i'm going to cast a
summon because that is the most powerful
spell i have and you can't stop me
but now summons will appear just because
the magical conditions are met but it
could be in a battle where you don't
need their help you know right
i don't know is there anything else we
want to talk about it is release day of
this i'm adding on we're already talking
about a dlc but no i mean i imagine in a
game like this if they do when they when
they do eventually release dlc it'll be
stuff that will reward people who've
been playing for a while i would assume
maybe more dungeons for the people that
did like 100 percent of this like 80
hours or however long it might take and
i'd like to reward them rather than
people that are just getting in i'm
curious too like you had final fantasy
13 2 final fantasy 13 3 final fantasy 10
2. like do you think they'll be like
like dlc could be final fantasy 15 too i
had that thought the other day but so
the the thing is the story doesn't leave
a lot of room for anything like that it
it there is there is
there's a little bit of room for it but
but not in the sense yeah that i can be
like oh yeah i can see where this is
going i could i could not tell you where
i think but the story might continue
maybe with like different characters or
is that in territory is that a different
final fantasy because i don't know the
tradition but like because i really do
love the world like i'm having so much
fun just exploring the world it'd be
cool to see dlc
i mean the world's already huge but
maybe after a while like have a new area
maybe not to the same size but a new
area you can go to maybe new characters
you play they're like a new sort of side
story kind of like you guys hang on
blood and wine earlier actually you know
what that brings to mind so so sid right
he's a recurring character in a lot of
final fantasy games he's in this one and
he is an old friend of your father
now there's a point in the game where
you see like it's not really a spoiler
you just see like a photograph of
sid and your father and two other guys
like 30 years ago right it's like
a mirror image of what you're currently
doing in the game but the generation
before you
i could see dlc that uses those
characters to tell the story back then
that that that's actually probably where
i would expect they could go and still
justify the dlc without having to jump
through hoops like how does this fit
right well it fits because it took place
before different characters maybe same
abilities or at least the same battle
system
interesting all right well that's final
fantasy xv and the dlc we kind of want
to see down the road but uh
yeah let us know what you guys think
once you play more of it what do you
think we could see in dlc down the road
where you think the story could go from
here what more additions to the open
world you want to see let us know in the
comments below
all right that's the show
we uh we didn't go half hour over
talking about titanfall 2 this week
unfortunately
we still can right yeah we could uh
so
anyway yeah there's a lot of games to be
playing right now pete you just got the
last guardian finally last night i'm
gonna be playing that reviewing that
don't oh my god that's creepy looking
sorry he's made a crazy face two games
ten year long wait it's like outright
it's it's crazy like you got them back
to back yeah yeah kind of a one-two
punch of holy [ __ ] i remember when this
was released i
have been driving legally since
like both these games have been like
when final fantasy
yeah i was same here
or i was not like i don't know freshman
high school anyway yeah i'm looking
forward to playing my first final
fantasy 15 tonight p you got last
guardian i'm assuming that's where
you're going to be playing uh jake more
final fantasy 15 as well i think more
final fantasy 15 maybe a little bit
titanfall in there cool hitman 2. i
actually really like hitman i think
we're all trying to wrap up like game of
the year contenders and just make sure
we played everything so
did you say hitman he did say hitman
anyway that's our show for the week as
always thanks for joining us jean-luc
eric tay mary kish in the back richard
lee cameraman always good to have you
guys setting the show up and everybody
else try to finish up as much games as
you can as many games as you can before
we get into uh our game of the year
videos in the coming weeks but until
then have a good week
[Music]
you